the oldest thing is the games were trade
straight away I was no different
soon as I finished skill absorbs getting
pestered what are you doing with your
life you know this they own that and
they didn't know what it was they didn't
know MMA wasn't known I just didn't know
it could make a career as far as they
were concerned me mind I'm talking about
as far as they were concerned I'm just
getting into a cage and fighting some
other guy they didn't know nothing about
it
no one did really but I knew and I mean
I knew or their and then I got it I end
up getting a trade just to keep them
quiet cuz it had a lot of fights Amidala
I end up getting a trade as a plumber so
used to go up there six o'clock five
o'clock in the morning I usually 14-hour
day so I always like this isn't for me
this is not for me I lasted 18 18 months
stealing but it was tough you know
it just it wasn't wasn't alive for me
and then John got on Twitter says I have
a show on the show would like to fight
honey and then that was he I just packed
it in didn't show up weed I used to come
in and punch the head on me and like try
and drag me out of bed and I just
wouldn't go I just packed it in quit and
then focus on training and that's I knew
I knew I knew what was gonna happen I
knew I was gonna get here they didn't
there's a lot of stressful years you
know I mean a lot of tough times and but
I proved them wrong I proved myself
right every gym I went heroes they had a
set way they have their own tanks don't
do it this way do it that way so that
was just a normal thing that I talked I
thought just people just have their own
set way and you must do it that way you
must stand this way you must kick this
way you must punch this way and I met
Michael John cabinet and it wasn't like
that
he had a more open mind and he
encouraged
different movements and I never
experienced that before I've never heard
a coach say that to me before
and that stuck in my head and I thought
to myself you know this guy is thinking
outside the box you know I mean that he
has a vision that everything works on a
knee he encourages every movement
because ultimately there is a time and a
place for every single move so I just
hot I just near one when I met John and
I when he spoke it made complete sense
to me and that was the I stuck with him
and he stuck with me and the rest is
history
you just watched two amazing clips from
Conor McGregor take the next three
minutes to sit quietly I think about how
to apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]